I do think as Global Bitcoin adoption
increases I think the power of these
institutions wanes and eventually they
they are forced to become smaller and
and more core to their original Mission
as opposed to like sort of resource
extraction machines I think that they
turn back into potentially like
collaboratively managed funds that do
things in the common interest like put
out fires when countries have issues
um I think that that's possible but I
think that's only possible if there's a
reform of the monetary Paradigm if we
remain on this dollar hegemonic system
like there's just no one no one has an
incentive to change this I use this
metaphor in the book but it's like a
drug dealer like that that the Western
creditors are dealing drugs to largely
unaccountable governments and
authoritarian countries and there's no
there's no one there to like put you in
therapy like there's no one there to say
maybe you shouldn't take this debt